Guten Tag, mein Name ist Ayiz, ich bin auf dieser Situation als Assistenz Arztetik und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen eine
Frage stellen Sie sich an, wie viel wiegt ihr?
14. März 1983
Wie viel wiegt ihr?
Ich wiege aktuell ungefähr 55 Kilogramm
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß
Was wird Sie sonst, Frau Mida?
Ich bin jetzt bei Ihnen, weil ich jetzt ungewollt Gewicht verloren habe, innerhalb von 3 Monaten.
Ich habe früher ca. 60 Kilogramm gewogen, oder 61 Kilogramm, jetzt wiege ich nur noch 55 Kilogramm.
Mir geht es auch nicht gut, ich fühle mich nicht wohl.
Sie haben in 3 Monaten ungefähr 6 Kilogramm abgenommen, habe ich richtig verstanden?
Genau, richtig.
Haben Sie noch eine andere Beschwerde?
Ich bin sehr schnell auf der Puste, aber auch bemerkt, dass ich Herzrasen habe und ich habe auch einen Zittern in den Händen.
Sie haben Husten?
Ich habe kein Husten.
Sie haben Husten geblieben, oder?
Ich bin sehr schnell außer Atem.
Und Sie haben Herzrasen und bei Ihnen Händen Zittern.
Ich habe auch eine sehr normale Ruhpulse, der ist zu hoch.
Sie haben alle diese Beschwerden ungefähr seit 3 Monaten.
Sie haben 2-3 Monate, oder?
Haben Sie Fieber, Nachweiß oder Stüffroß?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ich schwitze aber mehr als sonst.
Sie haben Atemnot und Herzrasen und diese Beschwerden sind belastungabhängig.
Ja, aber der Puls ist auch in Ruhe hoch.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stürkang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe jetzt viel häufiger Durchfall.
Seit einem Monat habe ich fast nur Durchfall.
Wie sah Ihre Stühle aus?
Z.B. Rot oder Schwarz?
Nein, die Farbe ist wie immer.
Es ist aber nur sehr wässrig, schleimig.
Sie haben auch Durchfall?
Sie haben auch Durchfall seit 3 Monaten?
Seit ungefähr einem Monat.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ich habe eigentlich einen guten Appetit.
Essen Sie alles gerne?
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie mehr ausfallen?
Ja, habe ich auch mehr.
Haben Sie vorherkrankungen oder leisen Sie ankrörenden?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schlaf?
Ich habe nicht schlecht aufs Schlaf.
Das habe ich vorher auch schon gehabt.
Aber es ist schlimmer geworden.
Haben Sie Gefühle, dass Sie Ihre Halsschwellungen haben?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentlich Medikamente ein?
Sehr selten.
Was nehmen Sie ein?
Kopfschmerz-Tablette zum Beispiel.
Okay.
Was Medikamente nehmen Sie beim Kopfschmerzen?
Meistens Parazitamol.
Oder Asperin.
Haben Sie Allegie vorhanden?
Ich habe keine Allegie, nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, gibt es Auslöse für die Beschwerden?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Brauchen Sie, Frau Müller, brauchen Sie.
Bitte?
Brauchen Sie.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Ich lauche nicht.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Akkord?
Sehr selten, bei Gelegenheit, bei Geburtstragen oder bei Feiern.
Okay.
Was trinken Sie gerne?
Komprimantwein oder Cocktail.
Okay.
Haben Sie mit dem Drogen Kontakt?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Zum Beispiel Mariona oder irgendwelche Drogen?
Meinen Sie, ob ich Drogen konsumiere?
Ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Ich habe einige Fragen über Familien an einem Nese.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern sind leider beide verstorben.
Herr sich im Beileid.
Und wissen Sie, wann Sie verstorben sind?
Also mein Vater, der ist an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Er hatte wohl eine Herzrhythmusstörung gehabt.
Okay.
Und meine Mutter hatte Darmkrebs gehabt.
Beide sind sehr früh verstorben.
Okay.
Haben Ihre Eltern noch schittüse Erkrankungen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Leidet er an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Er hat eigentlich hohe Kolosterinwerte.
Ansonsten hat er nichts.
Okay.
Und Sie haben keine Fieber.
Und Sie haben in der letzten drei Monaten 6 Joghurt abgenommen.
Und haben Sie irgendwo Schmerzen im Hals oder Brust?
Nein.
Engel mit Öl?
Waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden,
Ihren Hausarzt oder noch ein anderer Arzt?
Nein.
Das erste Mal.
Ja, Sie sind hier gekommen.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Krankenhaus.
Ich arbeite in der Krankenhie.
Kann ich nicht verstehen, wie der Hund...
Ich arbeite im Krankenhaus in der Radiologie,
als Krankenschwestaler.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin ledig.
Und wenn war Ihre letzte Periode?
Die war jetzt vor ungefähr 2 Monaten.
Da habe ich auch Störungen.
Das ist sehr unregelig in der letzten Zeit.
Haben Sie Partner?
Nein.
Okay.
Aber ich muss fragen,
kann es sein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Nein.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Amila.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft,
alles gegen Kinderkrankheit oder Covid-19?
Ja.
Waren Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten im Ausland?
Ich war nur in Holland.
Okay, Frau Amila.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Und jetzt werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen,
dann die Blut abnehmen.
Und dann werde ich einige Untersuchungen durchführen,
zum Beispiel als Schilddrüse-Ultraschar.
Und wenn ich alle Ergebnisse gesammelt habe,
werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Dann kann ich sagen, was Ihnen fällt.
Haben Sie etwas fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzurücken?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Bitte legen Sie sie.
Und komme ich gleich.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Ich hätte einige Fragen.
Darf ich?
Ja.
Haben Sie Veränderungen an den Augen bemerkt?
Ich meine hervortretenen Augen oder etwas?
An den Augen?
Ja, an den Augen.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, mir persönlich nicht.
Mir wurde auch nichts zugetragen.
Sind Ihre Beine angeschwollen oder ist Ihr Gesicht angeschwollen?
Nein.
Können Sie sich gut konzentrieren?
Zweifrage, zweifrage, dann auch andere Kollegen.
Danke.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Zweifrage, nicht einige.
Zweifrage, Maximum.
Bitte.
Ein, zwei, okay.
Ja, Frau Miller, leiden Sie unter Schluckstörung?
Nein.
Zweifrage, leiden Sie unter Heiserkeit?
Danke.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Haben Sie die Temperaturempfindlichkeit?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie häufig gehen Sie den Stuhlgang?
Zweimal ungefähr am Tag.
Dankeschön.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Wie ist Ihre Schlaf, so empfindlich, Ihre Schlaf auch?
Hatten wir schon gesprochen, ich habe jetzt etwas Schlafstörer.
Schlafstörer, okay.
Darf ich das machen?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit bemerkt, ob Sie ärgerlich sind als vorher?
Ein bisschen gereizt, sonst haben mir meine Arbeitskollegen gesagt.
Okay, danke schön.
Noch eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Bürügenägel bemerkt?
Was habe ich?
Bürügenägel.
Ja, ich glaube, die sind auch etwas brüchiger geworden als uns.
Genau wie die Haare auch.
Ja, danke.
Die Patientin hat, ist Geschwester und Radiologie gearbeitet.
Und deswegen noch andere Fragen stellen müssen, Kollegen.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Stehen Ihre Augen mehr nach...
Haben Sie schon bepracht mal?
Entschuldigung?
Die Frage wurde gerade gestellt.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Die Frage wurde eben gestellt.
Okay.
Gut zu hören.
Die Patientin hat irgendwelche Röntgenuntersuchung durchgeführt,
mit Kontrastmittel, hocam?
Nein.
Gut zu fragen.
Wie lange war die Arbeit?
3 Jahre.
Okay.
Ich habe alle Orte gemacht.
Danke schön.
Ich habe keine Kollegen gefragt.
Ich habe mich erst mal angefangen.
Ja, bitte.
Noch eine Minute.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberhard.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte den Fahrkurs vorstellen.
Hatten Sie Zeit?
Bitte.
Es geht um Anna Müller, die 42-jährige Patientin.
Sie kam zu uns heute wegen in 3 Monaten 6 Kilogramm Abnahmen.
Sie klagte auch Belastung abhängig, Tachikadi, sitender Hände,
Dübner, Hiperhidrosis, warmer Intoleranz, Chimsonia,
Allopecia und Durchfahrt.
Alle Beschwerden sind bestehend seit 3 Monaten ungefähr.
Die Beine wurden verneint.
Vor Erkrankung und Opies, eine Mese, unaufwählig.
Sie nahmen bei Bedarf gegen Kopfschmerzen, Parastomol ein.
Sie haben keine Alleggien und sie sind verständlich geimpft.
Reise eine Mese ist unaufwählig.
Rau, Nikotin und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Sie trinken Wein oder Cocktail im Feiern.
Sehr sehr viel.
Sie haben eine Mese, die seine Mutter an den Darmkrebs verstorben ist.
Sie haben eine Mese.
Arteriobe Tony. Sie arbeitet im Radiologie als Krankenschwester und sie sei ledig.
Als genealogische Anämpfese gab sie an, ihre Periode unregelmäßig sei.
Letzte Periode sei vor zwei Monaten.
Das war und meine Verdachtdiagnose ist hyperhydroidia.
Als Diagnose kommt die Herz-Rhythmus-Störungen und die Anämie und der Akut-Corner-Sendrom im Betrag.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich körperlich untersuchen,
mit der Periode prüfen, EKG verlassen und Blut abnehmen.
Dabei würde ich große Blutbilder leben, Nierenwerte, TSA, T3, T4 und Hensynuksparameter,
Blutzucker, Elektrolyte bestimmen lassen und Urumprobe veranlassen.
Und in diesem Fall, Tröderutracea, Tröderzoneografie ist sehr wichtig.
Deswegen würde ich Ultrasosoneografie durchführen.
Das kann man später erst machen.
Haben Sie die Patientin einen X-Oftalmus?
Die Patientin würde die Patientin verneint.
Sie haben eine Schildprüfe über Funktionen, also eine hypertyriose.
Was würden Sie noch an Blutabnehmen lassen, wenn Sie die Verdachtdiagnose haben?
Ich würde die Antiglobulin-Trak bestimmen lassen.
Ich konnte nicht mehr andere.
Es gibt diese TPO und Trak kennen Sie vielleicht, oder?
Ja.
Die sind wichtig, dass die Schildprüfen Antikörper sind, um zu unterscheiden,
ob es eventuell ein Hashimoto sein könnte oder ein... was könnte es sein?
Hashimoto oder Schildprüfe Adenome?
Was könnte es sein, wenn Track erhöht ist?
Graves.
Wie nennt es anders hier in Deutschland?
Mobus basado.
Ich habe gehört, basado.
Habt ihr noch nie gehört?
Nein, ich konnte nicht ändern.
Aber ich röschere.
Das könnte es auch sein.
Die Patienten haben meistens aber auch ein Exophthalmus.
Also, der größerte Augen, die man dann sehen kann hervorstehend.
Wie würden Sie denn so eine Schildprüfen über Funktionen therapieren?
Ich würde stationäre Aufnahme nehmen.
Und würde ich Troida statikum.
Troida statikum.
Und Beta-Bilocker auch.
Und J-Karenz-Ernörungs-Pileid.
Und, ja, das war es.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das ist gut.
Aber die Fazil muss auf jeden Fall stationär aufgenommen werden.
Da so Herz-Rhythmusstörungen auch gefährlich sein können.
Es könnte auch in einer theoretoxischen Krise enden.
Muss auf jeden Fall stationär aufgenommen werden, stabilisiert werden.
Und dann kann sie entlasten werden, nachdem Diagnostik gemacht worden ist.
Man würde eine Zintiga 4 auch nur dann machen.
Wenn wieder eine euthyriöte Lage ist.
Dann wäre das nicht eine Hyperfunktion da.